here with more reaction house gop
minority leader kevin mccarthy kevin so
i had newt gingrich on my show on my
radio show this week and we have him on
tv regularly and i ask him this question
you know what should the republican
party do it's easy to point out all the
failures of joe biden because i can't
point to a single success
we see the border we see energy record
prices for a gallon of gasoline we see a
40-year high of inflation we see a
disaster in afghanistan war in europe
nothing is going right at all because of
these policies
and i had a call to my radio show this
week asking specifically about you
and wanting to know whether i thought
that you and the republicans
mean what they say
in terms of what they will do if they
get a victory in november oh so i'll
give you the chance to answer
well you're right you've got to do more
than just criticize and this is where i
have a really strong different opinion
than mitch mcconnell
we are going to lay out to the american
public just like in the contract with
america and i've worked with newt about
this as well
it's going to be a commitment to america
and what will we actually do i've put
all of our members in
conference we have gone to different
task forces listening to the american
public working on solutions to our
problems
fiscal policy we're going to make sure
that we take this runaway spending that
the democrats have done that have caused
this irresponsible spending that has
caused inflation we're going to become
energy independent not just the way we
were before but we're going to be
dominant that we could actually help our
friends in europe because our natural
gas is 41 percent cleaner than russian
natural gas we're going to make our
streets and schools safe again not
defunding the police but funding the
police and making sure da's don't pick
and choose which law they enforce but
they uphold all the laws we have a
parent's bill of rights where the
parents have a say in their kids
education these are just a few of the
items but that's not all we're going to
hold this administration accountable the
first thing we'll do is stop bad
legislation but we're going to find out
where the origins of covet came from
from variant after variant don't we want
to know why and where it started so it
never happens again
we're going to investigate the attorney
general why did he go after parents and
call them terrorists simply because they
wanted to go to a school board meeting
we're going to make sure what happened
in afghanistan why did we have 13 new
gold star families because of the
decisions from this administration of
where they went wrong
this is just a few items going after the
irs releasing the tax returns of the
american public and yes we will need to
know who is the big guy and these are
the things that we can do in the
majority not just make our economy sound
again our energy independent where our
gas prices are lower our schools and
streets safe again but we will make our
schools open to their parents and make
sure this critical race theory is not
being taught but we will hold this
administration accountable we'll get
that commitment to the american people
long before the election there should be
a contrast that you have a clear choice
of which direction you want america to
go and it's not just for republicans
this is an american commitment and it's
about american policy and american first
we should not be dependent upon china or
russia in any industry be it medical be
it critical minerals or others we're
going to make sure america can depend on
themselves
if you do all those things and
your coalition if the republican party
does all of those things i would argue
it's also good politics
you recently went to brussels you met
with the leaders of nato i played a tape
of donald trump
dressing down the head of nato on how
stupid they were this is i think in 2018
uh because here it is we pay more
dollars than any other country to
protect nato allies from russia and then
these nato countries that don't even pay
an equal share in terms of gdp
uh turn around and make russia and putin
rich again putin is going to make close
to a billion dollars a day this year
alone
by it by selling oil and gas to western
europe i mean that that's a form of
madness they are funding the war in
ukraine by doing so
you're 100 correct we also went to
romania and poland and i will tell you
this sean they will talk about donald
trump as the individual that was right a
hundred percent they're no longer just
spending below they are now increasing
beyond two percent two and a half and
you know what else they realize their
strength is not just their military
their strength is whether they're
dependent or not dependent on other
countries in romania they are now
looking to purchase american nuclear
reactors the small modular reactors so
they can become energy independent they
do not want to be with
with russia or others they want to make
sure that america is about them and they
know american energy can help supply
them in environmentally sound way and
also in a place that they don't fund
what is happening in ukraine it's great
for our national security it's great for
job creation high paying career jobs in
the energy sector uh it's great for
lessening the load of inflation
everything will cost less
it could solve so many of our problems
and we can help out our allies in europe
anyway uh kevin mccarthy thank you for
being with us straight ahead hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis
you will not get it anywhere else